Hey, welcome to the channel design for leaders
and educators. This video is going to be on how
to ask questions to get the answers that you want. This is a question, ironically, that I get asked
fairly often. My job, I get to work with some of the
smartest and most talented leaders and educators
on the planet, and in this video I'm going to
share one major paradigm shift that the smartest
educators and leaders go through or make in order
to ask really phenomenal questions to get the
answers that they want. And the answers- and maybeeven more importantly the impact that they want to
have. The only fluff I like goes on a sandwich
and tastes like marshmallow. Let's get into it.
So, half of the paradigm shift is this, when
you think about asking questions to get the
answers that you want, on one hand you
think about asking leading questions,
right. Think about a lawyer, an FBI investigator,a cop, "Just give me the facts ma'am," right. They're
leading questions. They are asking- especiallya lawyer right, and the court is asking questions
that is aiming to get to a certain aim and
there's this intensity toward it, and the
witness or the person being asked questions feelsthat pull. Feels like you're leading them some way.
As opposed to over here, really phenomenal leaders
and educators ask questions that are exploratory
rather than leading. And the difference betweenasking leading questions over here and exploratory
questions over here is quite massive. It's the
difference between whether somebody trusts you
or not, it's the difference between somebody being
honest with you or not, it's the difference between
increasing psychological safety and decreasing
psychological safety, which I shared in many of
my other videos on the channel. The number one
predictor of high performing innovative teams
is the degree of psychological safety. And so,
over here these people's job is typically not to
increase psychological safety. If anything, it's
to make sure your heart rate's high enough,
at least in the movies, right. If you happen to
be a lawyer or an FBI investigator watching
this video, you get a pass, but the idea here is
you want people to feel psychologically safe
because the answers that I would argue that you
want- I don't know exactly what questions you're
asked, I don't know exactly what landed
you on this video, but the answer is I
would argue that you want are the most honest
ones. They're the answers that people
shared because they meant them, not because theyshared them to fit some view of what-
what they thought you wanted, right. Which happensa lot in leadership, the higher you go in a role of
leadership, the more people lie to you and tell youwhat you think you want to hear, as opposed to what
you really want to hear is truth. Working with
some leaders at high levels within organizations,
and universities, and schools, it is a unanimous
theme that people have to work harder to just
get authentic answers, authentic responses from
people that aren't super baked and prepared, and
you get the idea. In a moment, I'm going to
share the paradigm shift in the form of
some signs that I've got, but first, I want
to offer you the definition of adventure,
and it relates to getting the answers that you
want. Because somebody wants to find adventure,
for me, as embarking on an experience
where the outcome is uncertain. So,
typically you think "adventure" and it's like
classically conditioned with like skydiving.
That is thrilling, but hopefully the outcome is
certain. Maybe, actually it is adventurous because
you could die, right. There's thatelement of risk and yet a true adventure in a
conversational sense in an organizational sense is
any experience or conversation where the outcome
is uncertain. I would argue the best conversations,
the most memorable ones, the most impactful ones
feel like an adventure. You don't know
exactly where they're going to go. They're not
leading questions, right. And the paradigm shift
that I have noticed in some of the smartest
people on the planet is moving from a place
of making assumptions to a place of exploring
possibilities. When you're able to question your
assumptions, that becomes exploring possibilities.
But question them in a way that is rooted in zero
judgment whatsoever. Cop, FBI investigator, lawyer is
asking questions- they might be questioning their
assumptions, but they already know they're not even-
they're so deeply rooted assumptions that they
know the answer. There's no changing their mind
on what they think. Whereas I would argue that the
answers you want to get when you ask questions
are the ones that explore possibilities, because
these are the ones that lead to new product ideas,
better learning outcomes, higher engagement,
less turnover in your organization. This
paradigm has the potential to very much shift
every conversation that happens. Now, if you shift
you know one conversation from a place of making
assumptions to a place of exploring possibilities,
cool. But if you do this organizationally or, you know, across your team are able to make
that shift, what you get is a completely different
team. I have a firm belief that our entire world is
created through our speaking and our listening. I can't quite explain hurricanes with that mentality
or that theory but, the majority of your world
is shaped by speaking and listening. And so when we
change those things, I would argue that we actually
change the world. So, if you're not happy with the
current world that you're living in or the current
microcosm that you're living in, see what happens
when you're able to shift from making assumptions
to exploring possibilities. Now, in other videos, I
teach some really clever tips on how to ask better
questions. Questions that begin with "how" or "what"
and not "why" is a really great way to move from
that making assumptions to exploring possibilities.
I'm teaching people how to tap into their natural
genuine curiosity. Teaching people how to listen to
the music behind the words because that's usually
where the most possibility lies as opposed to just
listening for the facts and the words. And so,
training yourself in more wise ways to listen
really helps. Easiest, lowest hanging fruits to
shift from this paradigm is very simply moving
from closed questions to open questions. Here,
there are a lot of closed questions being asked.
Yes or no questions, things that put you in a
place at a certain time, that put you in a box
that don't allow for a lot of options and how you
answer them, right, maybe even multiple choice. A
leading question might look like, "Hey, were you
here or were you here on Friday, January 19th?"
Well, you don't have only those options as opposed
to over here, "What were you doing on January 19th?"
FBI investigator could still ask that
question, but this is a more open question.
It has less judgment. It pigeonholes people
less, and you don't want to pigeonhole people.
And if you're watching this video and you
want to pigeonhole people, this channel is
not for you, probably, because this channel is
about giving opportunities to amplify
connection, belonging, and trust. And so, move
from those closed ended questions to more
open questions that ask for stories, feelings, fears,
aspirations, the background story, right,
the whole picture as opposed to just one little image. So, after watching this video you're convinced that
you want to have conversations to ask questions
to get answers you love rather than ones you
want. You might really enjoy Will Wise's book, "Ask
Powerful Questions" There's a free version of it
in the link below. I'm Chad Littlefield, lovely
hanging out in cyberspace. Have an awesome day.